[Applause]
welcome back to down the middle
i'm really excited you know we recently
spoke with richard verner
who is world's prominent expert on
everything bank of japan 1989
everything that went wrong following
that spectacular episode
that culminated in more than three
decades of lost growth in japan
today we have with us somebody who can
really distill
what happened there but also explain the
implications
and why central banking and central
bankers
have taken on the same approaches
throughout the past few decades what
that implies and what it means for the
united states of america are we
going to be japanified so i'm delighted
to introduce to you george clone galvez
thank you for being with me today good
to be here first time in the city in a
while so a good time
it's over a year that's right this is
this is both of our first times
back in new york city this is the the
post covid
um the post cove road mission and and
it's uh
before we get to the road warrior who
you are
and everything you've seen why don't you
tell us a little bit about
what got you so interested in plumbing
i'm not talking about the plumber who
charges us too much money
not that but the financial system
liquidity
how it works how it behaves well i mean
i might actually go back to the plumber
analogies anyway because
there's obviously a lot of connections
to how you know liquid moves through a
system
um and i'm gonna just you know throw a
personal thing which i rarely do
um you know when i was growing up my
parents would always send me to portugal
for
the summer summer break so i would
always be there it's a mountain region
you know an agrarian type society still
and they had all these like levees and
little like
water dams and things like that sure and
i would always just play with them i
always kind of figure out
how fast things would move obviously
when you're a kid you're trying to
figure out how fast boats are going to
go down these little channels
uh you know all joking aside amsterdam
reminds me of answered anyways
yeah absolutely so um but in general
i've always been intrigued by
systems and how you know one one action
you know has another reaction and
figuring
out how things work through uh these
elaborate structures
and and the banking system you know
especially the plumbing
is is so complex especially in the us
more so than it is in europe and europe
has its own complexities but
in the us with uh parallel systems with
you know
an actual commercial banking system a
money market system
we have the the gses and all the kind of
government sponsor type lending
facilities
a lot of off balance sheet in general i
don't think the rest of the world
realizes or i don't think americans
realize that fannie and freddie
don't really exist in other countries
and that they're a larger debt market
than the treasury market
yeah so so it's it's it's amazing when
you start so i started off in my my
career
in on the merrill lynch money markets
desk and that's where i really kind of
got in you know involved in
understanding how repo works
uh and how to trade short-term
obligations and it was
it was late 90s at a point where
financial innovation was already
starting to
kick up in a very fast way a lot of the
you know civs asset-backed commercial
paper programs
all this stuff was looking for ways to
source cash
by posting some sort of collateral i
mean that you know
this is this is enron times yeah we were
you know
it was it was really just like the wild
west of liquidity
um and you know and it worked for a
while i mean it worked
you know even through we got through the
dot com crisis and it was not
it was not tied back to excess leverage
in the bond market or money markets i
mean there was there was parts of that
we had a
brief glimpse of that of course with
long-term capital right and the excess
leverage that was being employed there
to squeeze every little basis point to
put on these arbitrage trades
but you know that was really the start
of my career and
and i got really you know interested in
it and i i just
i read every single book possible out
there on on money markets
and over the course of my career have
built
my strategy framework around
understanding the flows understanding
the plumbing
understanding where there's gonna be
potential bottlenecks and pressures and
then around each of those nodes
look for what's priced in and what's not
priced in i mean i was also fortunate
enough to be
you know educated by some of the
smartest strategists strategists and
traders on the street and having worked
both at
merrell morgan stanley bank of america i
mean these were all great you know
uh premier names with you know amazing
people that were actually in the front
lines doing these sort of uh
activities so i really got a front row
seat of seeing
how you know the whole process comes
together it works
and everything it was you know obviously
working fine until we started to
you know as we all know go into the
subprime slash
right housing period of you know the
early 2000s
at that point that's when the wheels
almost came off as we know it was
leveraged upon leverage
uh but a lot of it was still it was it
was designed to
to satisfy a need which was a lack of
short-term collateral
there was not enough short-term paper in
the system
of high-quality assets so they were
making up triple a's as they go
credit rating agencies were going stamp
of approval aaa
and investors believed it and around
that time
uh you were i had just met you and you
were making a big change in your career
you were moving from one big firm to
another in a very turbulent time
in the markets oh sure i mean look i
mean i was
and really what was happening then was
just um
questioning around what is like you know
live board like we're funding
well you know it's access to dollar
liquidity right
before 2006 2007 before my change to my
the last shop that i was at um it was a
period of
realizing these excesses have built and
that there was just not enough actual
underlying to support it
and the fed of course eventually figured
that out
uh and and flooded the system with you
know even to this day on a
percentage basis what they grew the
balance sheet back then
we've never done so far right right
because they were starting from a base
of below a billion people forget that it
was eight hundred and some odd
the fed's balance sheet was eight
hundred and some billion
prior to the launch of all the
quantitative easing
yeah and even before that they had all
those liquidity programs which we know
like
you know we've discussed they've they
reintroduced during cobit because they
had them like you know on the shelf
somewhere
but background here for just a second
george was my chief
advisor when i was advising richard
fisher on the markets i didn't
understand the plumbing but i needed to
be able to explain it to president
fisher
george was my go-to man so throughout
all the crisis years when i was inside
the fed so f white
background anyways continue now thank
you yeah and look i obviously enjoyed
our conversations and
and working with you now as well um it's
it's um it's an area that people don't
really spend too much time on but now
they do they're starting but even then
they still don't get it at this point
and even even you know there's i mean uh
so who's
so yeah so zoltan zoltan poser who i
worked with at the
fed at the time i mean i had to make two
separate trips to new york
that's how i mean we spent two solid
days together in his office and the size
of the map of the financial system
took up his entire wall and he was the
only person inside the entire federal
reserve who understood the plumbing of
the financial system
and it still took me two trips to
understand what he was talking about
with this quote-unquote tri-party repo
system
at the very nucleus of everything that
was unfolding
after lehman went down that's right and
i've never seen that map and you've kind
of illustrated it for me
and i think he has like some paper out
there that i found like that's a fed
paper that he's published a lot of work
on that
one he's at the fed and of course now
he's on the private side
but it's it's complex stuff and then
it's hard to
make it relevant to what it means to the
the here and now in the markets right
until something like breaks breaks and
so it's all working all fine and good
if you if you go back and you look at
the shadow banking system and i i just
did some quick numbers
looking at these non-bank entities
uh like you know the gses like repo
desks
like you know i um
like the the credit component of private
equity i mean
if you look at all the ways that you can
source cash around
the us financial system that's not
sitting on a bank deposit
towards institutions balance sheet so i
think the biggest banks bank of america
jp morgan the cash they actually have on
their balance sheets outside of that
universe outside of that universe but
even just their overall deposit base not
their cash but
customers cash you know money market
funds all that stuff
right now from what i calculate they're
almost like an even split of like 20
trillion
off balance sheet and 20 trillion on
balance sheet
for a total of about 40 odd trillion and
i i was doing this last week because the
z1 data came out and
i was just playing around trying to
figure out yeah yeah and i was and i was
like wait
so let me run that those numbers
backwards what did they look like in
the shadow banking system was bigger
than the real banking system i remember
timothy geithner made a speech
uh and he said that it was 17 trillion
dollars at the time
and people were like wait wait that's
bigger than the conventional banking
system
yeah exactly so if you add those two
together and then
i i feel like what we have to do going
forward i think people are starting to
get on with this idea
normalize everything by excess reserves
if you do at the peak of so wait explain
what an excess reserve is
or just reserves in general right so the
fed
through its quantitative programs uh has
created you know electronic cash or
reserves that get deposited
uh at the the fed t accounts of
individual banks
because they're buying 120 billion
dollars of securities every month that's
right post covet
sure and and before that they bought x 3
trillion before that so right
so in total since the financial crisis
close to six and a half trillion or
something
so all that qe and what they're buying
has to get you know credited somewhere
in the system it gets credited as a
reserve pre-crisis we did not have a
large reserve
system because you know the banks had a
different like regulatory regime in
general
but also there was just like really that
oversight was not there
plus you know the you know there's a
view that the banks were self-regulating
themselves in a way where
oh yeah those are high quality liquid
assets they can sell them on a dime if
they have to raise cash right
and of course and then the crisis came
and we went whoa where'd the liquidity
go
if i'm right and maybe i'm off by a
couple multiples but it doesn't really
matter
it was like 777 times
the level of reserves on to in december
like 777 times larger
when you combine shadow banking and the
overall uh you know
paper thin cushion very paper thin now
actually we are at 14 because the fed
has pumped in so much base money so the
monetary base
like this is the part that i've been
struggling you and i've been talking
about this school last year
because you know because now all
everyone's like worried about all this
printing of money and everything and and
and i think as you mentioned you know
you know which richard werner in your
intro uh you know also has been like a
spearhead
on this in this concept it's not the
central banks that really
create the money that goes out into the
real economy it's the commercial banking
system
or the shadow banking system either or
right but it's the private sector that
pumps in
excess dollars when people take out a
loan and that's why
that's why purists get so mad when they
say that the fed is printing money
yes the fed is not printing money
technically if the fed wanted to print
money then the fed's
liabilities would be legal tender and
there would be no auction process that's
right
just go out but the federal reserve act
1913 dictates the federal reserve can
only buy
treasuries in the secondary market and
that brings in
an outside presence which is the
commercial banking system so yes they
still operate so they have to their
monetary policy is still
somewhat some would say the the the
non-purists or the ones that are or the
mmt years
like oh that's a constraint we shouldn't
have to go through the banking challenge
just like pump it right into the into
the economy and then then like we'll see
what inflation does at that point
uh-huh don't jump ahead but yes we would
yeah i know so but that right now we're
about 14.
i went back and i took that number all
the way back because the z1 data goes
back to 1945
like because that's one good post-war
data that we have and
it was also about 14 19. so basically
the fed
has de-risked the the the off-balance
sheet
system and also made the commercial
banks very
cash rich you can argue that means that
they're strong i guess
but you're speaking with you know 770
times versus
14 times but specific to the commercial
to the conventional banking system
including shadow banking yes
okay because they're both now roughly
about 21 22.
because the shadow banking stalled after
the financial crisis actually dipped
but it's been growing back up again in
the last five years as you know there's
been a lot of just you know you know ceo
activity there's been a lot of just
overall
think of private equity in the mountains
of dry powder and the billions of
dollars that they've raised
yeah so that that part has been on the
upturn but the commercial banking system
i actually am not
too terribly concerned about you know
where they stand i mean they're super
capitalized
i mean they own assets that can go down
in value like everybody else
right but i mean if you think about you
know here we are in manhattan you know
full of one high-rise after another and
yet
the largest bank's exposure to
commercial real estate which was very
problematic in 2007-2008
that's not the same situation today yeah
no agree there's actually
smaller banks but smaller banks however
yes they took up the slack of that and
that's a whole other
yeah there's obviously differentiation
within the banking system i don't want
to like throw out a blanket statement
but i'm not that concerned there but so
if the fed de-risked the system
and now we i think we just you know
heard some news that they're
not extending the relief on the slr
supplemental leverage ratios yes thank
you um
perhaps like they're really you know
they're asked to like hey banks start to
lend
right because the only way they're going
to be able to
[Music]
grow into it grow into this excess cache
that's in there they have to start
blending out
right and then hopefully that creates a
money multiplier right so there's
so there's another thing to stop and and
this is an educational moment if you
will
um the amount of money in the system
m2 as we call it is extraordinary
but maybe you could parse out the
difference between a lot of money
being in existence and whether it's
moving or not
no and it's not so and then you know
like the inflation is i'm i'm look i've
i've been a
uh diehard deflationist and it's worked
well for me because
about 40 years now yeah the last 40
years has been the right move to be
the bond market's going to tend to be
right over time because
more debt more debt more leverage harder
to finance it
this inflationary pressure is
globalization and people don't
understand that that
the the simple creation of money is kind
of by definition
deflation because you have to service it
all that's right so and is it
unless it's put into circuit unless you
pick up velocity
you're not going to get inflation it's
velocity or you do dead jubilee and you
actually extinguish debts and that's not
going to happen anytime soon in the us
we'll have bigger problems according to
china yeah and and
so i i think this idea that we're going
to grow our way out of this and we're
going to somehow
see like all this fiscal spending amount
to
a robust sustainable recovery i think
you and i probably agree that
it's more like a flash in the pan it's
gonna you know increase activity but
then we'll see on the other side right
but let's say that we're wrong and they
just somehow say like you know they're
shaking the magic money tree and they're
going to keep
doing all this fiscal spending who's
going to buy all this stuff
right he's going to buy all the
treasures and we're going to get there
we're going to get there too yeah
but first i want to go back in time a
little bit
uh so you are a study
of because when you were at no more you
went to how many countries and how many
once a year you were everywhere yeah
like uh
yeah so uh given that you know i worked
at a formerly worked at a japanese bank
and
and there were obviously a huge presence
in asia uh i spent a lot of time in asia
probably
three to four times a year um and
i lost count i had like three passports
i went through like three passports in
the course of
almost a decade because i had to and i
kept expanding them and then they
stopped allowing you to explain yeah try
being in dallas trying to
get you to be in new york when i'm like
okay we're in the middle of a crisis or
would you quit hopping around the globe
already and get get in new york
well anyone that knows me and knows my
style of work ethic
i'm on like almost 24 7. and so if you
want to find me you could probably find
me somewhere
virtually but uh but you know um i don't
know i think probably 90 countries
it's it's an it's an insane number now
and i'm very grateful for all the
opportunities that i had and
i've met some amazing investors and that
further educated me because
i look i'm not a phd economist i mean i
think and i think most of my investors
and people that
clients that like me over time like me
because i'm i'm
i'm the real deal and i just call it as
i see it i've iterated over the years
my process and approach i got trained by
some of the best people on the street
and i've been just kind of improving my
process right but i i don't get stuck
not much more tactical instead of these
super long-term views that who knows if
they're ever right anyway
so i'm much more like you know you got
plumbing
uh understanding the system having
honest conversations with clients
and but but but this experience of being
exposed to so many different kind of
investors really enriched me to a point
of
understanding that you know it's not
just the american
way or outlook of on the economy we have
to think about
especially japan and having worked at a
japanese institution well you got to see
what you got to see how hard a central
bank
could try to raise inflation and fail
i mean you know as we were both getting
ready for this
you know overnight you know the bank of
japan finally
raised a small white flag and said okay
maybe this isn't really working the way
we want for it to work
and this was the first concession in so
long
i don't know yeah i i agree but but but
back to japan for for a minute a few
weeks ago you sent me
a chart that blew my mind because we
looked today we look at the s
packs and the ipos and the fever and
you know the teenagers who are on reddit
and robin hood and bitcoin and
i'm like this is just an amazing bubble
and you're like you want to see a bubble
so you sent me a chart and at the peak
of the dot-com bubble in 1999-2000
the price-to-earnings ratio was
somewhere around 45. in the u.s
at the peak of the nikkei bubble it was
99.
yeah depending on which calculations are
you know it was up there like 70 90.
a multiple of two whatever it was when
it was crazy here
so i mean that leads me to believe that
bubbles can get
bigger they can
however i just don't think the market
structure in the u.s is
is the same way that you can have such a
concentration like what took place in
japan
literally japan is an island but even in
the way their their financial markets
are designed
and and the fact that it was much more
inclusive and there was less
kind of like who owns japanese sovereign
bonds
well you know majority of the japanese
right and how does that differ from the
united states yeah we're for
the foreign nation and look and there's
a whole host of different differences
between the two nations but
but at that point in time the
the goal and the objectives of of how
and you know richard warner
has that amazing book in that right i i
only really got to know
of him or got reintroduced to him when i
saw that video that we
once saw oh the documentary yeah i'm
literally like stopping people in the
street i finally shut up about the
social dilemma and now i'm like you
gotta watch princess of the end
so no it's absolutely and it's amazing
how
they took something that was like a
wartime finance
uh objective of just keeping your
economy always building stuff even if
you don't need to build stuff right
and it just built out these massive
access accesses in the system
uh and then and then and then on top of
that the leverage that was being
afforded to anyone that had a heartbeat
right so i mean that's different than
what the federal reserve the federal
reserve's
trying to incent lending
yes so there's yeah there's not like
this window dressing kind of
we're going to force you to have x
amount of
specific lending quotas per year i doubt
the fed will ever get to that point
i just don't think that that's within
their their their remit and also
i mean i know like we a lot of folks
including ourselves like to give the fed
grief
but they're operating with huge
constraints around a global dollar
system which again is also part of the
plumbing aspect which you have to get
familiar with
and they themselves don't know where
everything is they don't know where all
the
dollars lie where all the obligations
are i mean
i mean in broad terms can you
can you set apart the dollar funding in
the united states
versus the dollar funding offshore
sure very simplistically i mean so since
they don't have access i mean size
oh size yeah roughly 12 12-ish i mean it
depends right you know the fed just
pumped in
like another couple couple trillion and
as we've written before in the past
a lot of the dollars actually are
outside the u.s anyway right they both
the hard cash as well as uh you know
some of the liquidity
i mean let's say 12 to 14 on a given day
trillion um and
they're not reservable assets they're
not they're against either treasuries
what they have to own
or china and japan yep but they don't
have access to the federal reserve's
balance sheet
they're not directly going through that
channel which the u.s banking system has
right so
so look it's um it's fascinating to
to you know to think like we can maybe
replicate a japanese type bubble but
because we're the reserve currency
and the fed is still trying to
they're trying to be methodical even
though they've changed their new mandate
on
the inflation targeting i just don't
think they're gonna let the wheels come
off
well they're certainly doing everything
they can to prevent that
but in doing so and
you get asked all the time i get asked
all the time is this 1999 or is this
2007.
my stock answer is yes it's just yes but
it but
but the leverage lives in a different
place today than it lived in
2005 2006. sure and and maybe it's by
design like you just
distribute all the leverage into a lot
of different pockets and you kind of
deal with all these many fires as they
go
i mean like well the corporate debt
market's pretty good
it's big it's better and that's why they
did what they did
last you know basically this time last
year right they had to address the
corporate bond market
it's you know i was thinking about it on
the way in and i was
maybe this is not going to be uh pc but
i'll say it anyway you're in the right
place yeah the central banks
are always fighting the last war right
and or the last battle whatever you want
to call it and
it's almost in a way like how
industrialists and
and overall just globalists are now
obsessed with esg and
somehow we have to fix all the wrongs of
the past of all the pollution that was
created
and you expect to fix that overnight i
mean it does not happen
and then central banks are faced with
the same challenges their predecessors
give them like another bubble they're
like all right you deal with it
and i'm like oh how do i deal with it
okay i'll just do more of the same
like how does that fix anything yeah i
mean if you
if you i mean it's funny it's funny
because now we have we have yellen
and we have yellen's former deputies and
they're now
inside the treasury and they're looking
at revisiting dodd-frank
i'm like wait a minute wait a minute
we've we're in a different place than
revisiting dodd-frank today sure
simple as that but anyways but but so
but
to answer the question though i answer
the question i say yes is this closer to
1999-2000 or closer to 2007 in your view
uh i would say it's more like 2 000 than
2007 okay because
although there is elements of the credit
market that
are super levered and there's zombie
companies and there's
you know a lot of just a lot of leverage
actually just
just last year alone that was um
unleashed because rates were so low and
there was like this mad dash for credit
yep
like those those those investors whoever
bought into the credit market we're
seeing in the lqd and you're seeing it
like they're gonna they're gonna be
nursing losses unless rates start
rallying back hard
right so you've kind of locked in people
last year into
permanent losses on their fixed income
that they bought during a pandemic to
help keep things together okay fine you
can say
it's a throwaway there's a two three two
three trillion dollars of
corporate debt issuance in america one
year at a loss yep
now sitting at a loss sitting on paper
losses paper losses yeah they're fine
there are losses right it still
impacts overall total returns and
portfolios when people look at it my
bond portfolio is not really doing
anything
any longer so at you know at this point
it but it's not like the same sort of
leverage like we had in o7 which was
like cdos squared and cbo it was like
leverage upon leverage upon leverage
so it won't cascade as much it shouldn't
just like
it won't start to amplify if something
really goes bad and it's not
concentrated on bank balance sheets yes
and off bank balance sheets so that's
why it feels a little bit like a
supercharged version
of the tmts that we saw coming out like
you know
the world comes right you know coming
out of uh of 2000
into 2002 when we realized oh look these
guys cannot service their debt and they
have too much of it
right you know i feel like i mean that's
why we say one out of every five
large us companies is a zombie yeah they
can't you know
if there's a bit if there's a blip they
can't service their debt yeah so that's
i mean i feel it's more like a death by
a thousand cuts on the credit market
and the fed wants to control it i mean
they want to basically try to ease the
pain
and elongate it as long as possible with
the hopes that the economy
will then increase to service those cash
flows
that's the bet they're making so
they're also trying to control two
distinct phenomena right now so maybe
you can take us back
uh i'm sure you'll never forget the
weekend i'll never forget the weekend
when
when steve mnuchin put out a formal
press release
that said you know i've spoken to all
the leaders of all the u.s banks and
everything's fine
and everybody went what did he say and
why did he say it
and why did he say at poolside at cabba
what was so important that he needed to
pull away from his vacation
but steve mnuchin understood a lot about
the financial system
so that was the beginning of
what people call repo madness but they
don't begin to understand
that's that's right that's really that's
100 right i mean
this look think about it that's now
going on well two and a half years two
and
two years and a quarter september yeah
but this is prior to september
of 19. yeah so two years and a quarter
right
so it's over two years now since that
happened but it feels like it almost
yesterday in my mind and i'm sure to you
too
and it's again that i agree with you
that's that is the marker
of when we knew that something was up
yep
that was the starting point but because
there's so much liquidity in the system
in general
it kind of like you know washes away
some of these things and and then of
course we have pal pivoting hard in
january
right but prior to that the fed was
raising interest rates and the fed was
shrinking its balance sheet and
the market you know was screaming you're
tightening too much and i mean this was
yeah there was a double barrel
tightening of rates and uh quantitative
tightening right which i was
very vocal about that as well uh and
they're like oh it's like watching paint
dry it's like you know
balance sheet on autopilot but then two
weeks later the autopilot got thrown out
the window yeah that was some
that was some scary paint that was
drying that was like blood paint it was
bad anyways
yeah so i feel like because
the i mean obviously the policy makers
want to make sure that the core of the
system is
is is obviously steady and held attacked
and held intact
i mean i i think it wasn't was kind of
an awkward
message because a lot of people were
looking at each other like why was this
being released
now but it was happening right around
the time where there was
big changes in reserve balances
uh within the system kind of like what
we're seeing now too
right right right uh and the fed was
like it was like the one last big kind
of quantitative tightening part
and it all just kind of uh ended
in that last week of you know 2018
around christmas week
into the to the new years i feel like it
was a panic
move personally speaking but because of
what was happening
in markets in the jitters it was
i think it was more to signal a sense of
calm but now they realize
we cannot the banking systems plumbings
and how
cash flows operate this is very micro
like intraday like you know when does
when does something happen at 8 30 in
the morning versus 10 30 in the morning
has a huge consequence of like who's
short cash
at that window right during that window
so i feel like you know it's like was he
trying to
calm those fears it was also during the
break and the markets were going down a
lot
i think it was a signaling effect but
but but the root cause this i think
at a minimum i want to dwell on it they
realized it was the
liquidity shortfall that you can't take
reserves down too much
right plus you had as as you
explained to me at the time you also had
the world crack the world kind of
crowding into
physical currency physical dollars
and at the same time you know outside
u.s borders there were major economies
that had
negative interest rates so their central
banks would come to the federal reserve
looking for positive
some place some place to park there and
that was that that was
that was half of what was going on in
terms of the tightening the quantitative
tightening was
was in addition to that so and and so
there were just a lot of things
culminating i'm sorry you're right and i
forgot
i should mention that too because when
people look at the defense balance sheet
they don't look at the pieces of it
right especially on the liability side
and and it is wonky stuff so you almost
kind of throw it all into one big
you know big pool but yeah that's a lot
of hundred dollar physical hundred
dollar bills
people are like currency in circulation
but also yes these f the foreign
reverse repo or the the ability of
central banks from other countries to
deposit money at the fed
because the fed just basically was the
last hike in december
right so yeah and then came then came
the power pivot yeah
exactly um so we don't have to go
through
everything that happened in valmageddon
and and
leading up to not not qe but um
what culminated with not qe and you you
pegged this at the time
um and headed into 2020. so this is
towards the end of 2019
and the fed is doing what it can you
explain what not qe was
it was well they're in their eyes when
you're buying short-term treasuries that
are
similar in maturity profile to reserves
which they're not they're a little bit
longer than
over up to 12 months up to 12 months but
it's overnight money and it's short-term
in nature
like t-bills they're buying t-bills it
was primarily targeted at t-bills at
that time
that it's it's really neutral
and it's not necessarily adding you know
actual
it's not the original definition of qe
q8 the qe that's like meant to do credit
easing
force people out the risk spectrum make
it easier to get a mortgage
you know whatever yeah and lower term
premium to buy mortgages
and to buy you know longer term credit
they were viewing that the not qe is not
meant for that
and in reality though
in a way and this is just you know in
hindsight thinking through what they did
perhaps they exacerbated what happened
into march of 2020
by taking out the high quality
short-term assets that everyone wants
right which goes back to my initials and
at the time some very
quiet credit market players who'd been
around for a very long time were saying
there's there might be too much leverage
building up on corporate balance sheets
and we might
we might we might start being you know
losing trust
in some of the credit and that was
happening in the background
and when we were speaking back then
you kept saying to me and it's taken me
a long time to figure it out
you kept saying to me the system wants
real qe
the system wants they want the real
thing but the fed couldn't
launch true quantitative easing credit
easing the way it was post-financial
crisis
without a crisis that's right so
you know i know it's blasphemous to say
uh but the fed needed a crisis headed
into 2020.
look the mean it was either gonna be
natural born and unfortunately obviously
it came by the pandemic right or it was
gonna be that the markets were to
at some point have a sudden stop and
demand it and demand it there i mean you
would actually just see credit spreads
go anyway
widening so the the the conclusion would
have been the same
just the catalyst is different right the
thing that
we have both observed which is amazing
they were they were there
waiting and ready oh they had that thing
and i don't
think that people quite appreciate i
mean i was inside the fed when we were
lowering rates to the zero bound
and at the time it was very dramatic and
oh my gosh they're getting close to zero
and what's going to happen if we get
interest rates to
blah blah blah and then oh they had to
get to zero before they could launch
quantitative easing and start start to
grow the balance sheet
but that took that took months and
months
and what happened on march 23rd 2020
took five minutes
yes and it was everything that we had
seen leading up to
the first time the united states had
zero interest rates plus quantitative
easing
plus new things new things yeah no no
i mean this has been battle tested there
was probably there was a
war room somewhere out there where all
these hypothetical scenarios were thrown
out there
this is the this is the bat the playbook
right you go like this
and you see if it start it stops the
bleeding and you see at what point
does it turn in my my view i think
you share a lot of it they went a little
bit too far
especially uh on the size of the
treasury impulse but you know there was
hundreds of billions of outflows that
were happening uh at that time too and
so
it was such a fluid period and i think
that
they want to calibrate which we can get
to later on how they
how can they ever taper but uh but i
think
it was just a heavy-handed response
and then throwing in all these new
credit vehicles uh
into it yeah or the state of illinois or
the mta here in new york or any any i
mean
so many different when i was inside the
fed
we debated for months corporate credit
we debated for months separately
municipal credit
and it was all like right then but
that's why it goes back to december
2018.
they knew that the clock started ticking
at that point
agreed i agree i agree i agree so um
explain um so we know
that today we've come full circle
so how on earth could we be back
with all this qe and continued qe
with a situation where
at the shortest end of t bills one month
three months they're trading negative
they're in such
demand and at the same time people
are i mean on the same day that one
month and a three month
treasury bill traded negative the lower
the yield the higher the price
the long bond almost to 2.50
the higher the yield the lower the price
on the same trading day
what on earth is going on i mean these i
mean i haven't seen a 70 handle
the dollar prices actually looked at
like high yield bonds long term
treasuries were trading in 70 dollar
prices which is
i mean you don't you when you think of a
bond you're like you're always like oh
it's close to par
it's close to 100 bucks i'm gonna get on
it it's a treasury and it's it's like
it's been backed by the us government
you're gonna get 100 bucks in 30 years
but you don't probably want to wait that
long either
right so you know what what hap what's
what's been happening and this goes back
to
my first part of the conversation why
i'm so fascinated by plumbing
and and how we're st we've done a better
job of fighting the last
battles but we've introduced other
constraints that has made it
more difficult to allow the liquidity to
flow to where it needs to go
and we haven't built or haven't produced
enough
short-term collateral right and this is
why the feds should not have bought all
these t-bills they should like
and i actually argue they should sell
those t-bills let the market have them
that's a different story we can talk
about later
but they there's there's a scarcity
of where to park your cash on an
overnight basis
and it's happening at a time where
there's a flood of liquidity
that's coming from the two pieces which
we both know which is
the fed is still doing qe 120 billion
every month comes in
and it goes into the system but we also
have now
you know as part of the the biden fiscal
stimulus plan
and with what we were you know uh at
least
prior to the plan but i'm sure they're
we're seeing in the numbers therefore
they are doing it
uh you know janet yellen uh treasury
secretary
gave it laid out a plan of how they're
going to use the cash that they've built
up last year
so so for people who don't i said this
is this is all plumbing this is all
liquidity this is all complicated but
let's just say that the united states
government has a checking account
yes and they have that checking account
at the federal reserve bank
yes so as as treasuries are issued
that cash has got to go somewhere that's
right because they've sold the debt so
they've got to put their cash somewhere
yeah that it's a temporary resting point
before they distribute it
for military uh expenditures
income tax returns security payments
sure i mean basically everything that
the government pays out money for
comes one way back to the tga in some
fashion or another but there was a lot
of
it after as as as the administration
changed over
yeah and that's the part that they were
so we don't have to go into politics but
but we
but it is political in many ways because
all throughout last year
uh the initial reaction was
borrow as much as you can because rates
are low right and let's just try to
raise money
to to to fund the cares act because who
knows
yeah everyone was you know scared what
kobe may actually turn out to be
so they overborrowed last year too right
so the checking account balance was
higher than it needed to be
yeah because there wasn't enough there
weren't enough recipients out there to
send
money to that's right it's like you know
as if you went and borrowed more
on your home equity line and then like
oh i'm not going to build that extension
now it's just sitting there and you're
like okay well maybe i'll build it next
year
but it's it's in many ways it's it's
it's it works like that
so they had over a trillion and a half
almost like 1.8 i think at the peak
yep which was actually in a way also
you know good timing on the part of
treasury mnuchin at the time
because the money markets needed a place
to park the cash
right and this is where it gets this is
the rabbit hole that i keep getting
myself
down and sometimes i hope i'm being
clear with with those that are viewing
and reading my stuff well so to
differentiate uh
when qa when negative interest rates
initially came about
in europe i it wasn't this like defcon
one disaster for the money market fund
industry
in europe i remember several of them
closed because that
there's not as many of them yes over
there
like i said before the shadow banking
system which a good chunk of
that 20 trillion is about four and a
half trillion
money market funds right so that's a
very unique aspect of the u.s
financial system yes okay and people
look view them
as synonymous to having money at the
bank
to most americans just means cash money
market funds is cash
it's either at their brokerage account
or they actually hold cash in it like
it's like you know
it's a higher yielding asset most of the
time um
so yeah so it's if you've got a
brokerage account and you have your
money swept
their sweep it's swept into a money
market fund and it's there
so it's money good right and within all
the legal constraints of
protecting the dollar um in the nav
so in a way and i was writing about this
i was writing about this at the time and
i thought like they had to
have issued those many t-bills because
if they had not
then those money funds that people were
being defensive selling their equities
drawing down cash getting that took a
while for that money to go back into the
markets over the course of 2020 but
initially
they just raised a lot of cash and also
by the way institutional funds
saw a lion's share of that because all
the corporate treasurers
panicked it was like we're going to shut
down the economy i got to make sure
i hit my credit lines and borrow dollars
because dollars are
cheap so it was kind of like it was kind
of like i see the forecast
there's hail storms for as far as i can
see i'm going to max out my home equity
line of credit just in case i totally
lose my roof three times
but all the corporations did that when
covet hit together that's right and it
was just a massive flood
that went to the money funds and the
money funds really did not have a place
to put it so
it was actually really good timing on on
treasury secretary mnuchin
former last year to issue over you know
a couple of two and a half trillion it
was basically doubled the size of the
t-bill market
uh last year and that allowed a home
for for all these well the cash flow
cash warning yeah
in the process of doing that they over
borrowed at the same time
and then that money sat on the fed's
balance sheet so now you have
money markets which are outside the
banking system they are
you know with these t bills that they
were now allowed to buy into
if they had not had that they have this
thing called the reverse repo program
which the bigger money market funds
would be have been able
google it just google it trust us yeah
the rrp is going to be important
going forward especially what happened
this week with the fed and increasingly
the overall
counterparty limits it's going to be a
bigger story going forward
so you know long story short the rrp
is a place to park your cash it's at
zero but you know it's not really an
attractive investment
and t bills were offering some yield and
the us government wanted to
pre-fund just in case we did a stimulus
2.0
right which most people expected for
trump to sign into law
before christmas yes and that didn't
happen before christmas 2020 and that
didn't happen
right because of all the political
infighting right right and how it got
dragged out all the way through beyond
the election
and regardless of where you stand on
that it literally
cost the american public access to
capital when they needed
because that money was there it was
already borrowed so now we have now
what's happening in this administration
they had that money because it was
passed on to them from the other
administration
and they're they're they're spending it
i mean they've already spent like right
400 billion i think in a sense the 1.9
trillion dollar
stimulus package was partially
pre-funded
because the money was already sitting in
the in the government's checking account
yes but that means that they're not
issuing they're not issuing t bills
to satisfy that they're not they're not
selling fresh
debt to to finance the 1.9 trillion yeah
and
and the investors that need that
securities to put their money in
they're not getting it because now
there's so now what's happening is a
scramble to find
anything that has yield or sometimes
they're going into negative
right that's why we've got t bills
trading at negative yields which is
bizarre
at the same time that you know you've
got
all these these movements in the nasdaq
i mean the fang stocks that
all of these uh i remember that they
were called the new utility stocks
because they were money good and they
were the best place to park your money
now they're being treated uh on any
given day
that interest rates are rising people
are like sell the nasdaq
it's just incredible yeah i mean it's
becoming other side of a duration trade
right but like but back to the t-bill's
thing which i know maybe it's a little
bit too boring but it
it's so um critical to the function of
what what's taking place
and and it goes back to what we
discussed how the fed basically is
burning the curve on both sides
right both ends of both ends now
they have they have a number of
quagmires to resolve
now they've skipped on the slr but then
there was a follow-up kind of
message that i saw quickly before our
conversation which shows that they're
going to
think about how they're going to tweak
it over time because they're going to
have to tweet they always leave the door
open
they're not going to say like this we're
done this is going to be we're not going
so they have that optionality now
that because they know they're going to
be pumping in trillions upon trillions
of reserves
right encumbering the banking system so
right so at some point the checking
account balance will be i'm sorry
it will be run down yeah so we're in the
process of the treasure the checking
account getting run down
the reserves are getting pumped up in
the banking system and we're about to go
into tax season so
the treasury's going to be mailing out
all kinds of tax refunds yeah so
same time as the stimulus payments and
the new unemployment benefits
so there's all this money coming out of
the government's checking account yes
and if you i mean there's some like
chatter on twitter and i'm sure you came
across
it how banks are holding back on cash or
distributing the stimulus checks because
there's so much cash
in the system right now right that's
coming out of the government side
that the banks don't even know what to
do with it and so they were just
ironically it was a lot of it i suppose
he was embargoed for the 17th
but which was yes yesterday for people
that are or
two days ago uh for those that are
listening um
you know there's fed day people maybe
are watching or we're hoping this will
all be extended
long story short we're dealing with the
next three months
close to you know one and a half more
trillion dollars
coming our way right that's
bigger than what was released during
covid initial response
in total once you do an annual change i
mean that money has to go somewhere
before the need presents itself for the
government to start borrowing
again that's right in the t-build market
yes so
negative rates the fed has that that
dilemma right
they didn't really do much this time
other than expand the rrp program's
counterpart limits they they they
went from 30 billion to 80 billion for
any given money market fund
to park their money at the at the fed to
get yield because they can't go into the
into the t-bill market because yields
are negative that's right because i mean
at this point negative rates versus
trying to translate as we go i promise
no no
i'm sorry if i'm going too technically
no no it's it's but this is really
important stuff
yeah because i mean who wants to have a
negative t-bill rate i mean
unless you're forced to like
institutions have to but if you can then
park your cash to fed get zero at least
zero you're not losing anything
right exactly and they're not allowed
money market funds are not
and some of them are still losing money
because it does it's not free to run a
fund
so there are administrative costs so um
let's skip ahead to the great debate
so you know my my beltway contacts
suggest that because they're
because the administration and the
democratic-led congress
can paint infrastructure spending
as being covered relief
that they might be able to pass another
three or four trillion dollars
in stimulus in 2021 under the auspices
of coveted relief and therefore use
reconciliation
only 50 senate votes need it to pass the
legislation instead of getting that
60. so what if my
beltway contacts are correct and what if
inside this year
so that the treasury balance the the
uncle sam's checking account
balance is depleted we get past this
short-term liquidity crisis
all of a sudden we're going the other
direction yeah then it flips and then it
flips and then
uncle sam starts to borrow a ton of
money let's say you get a three trillion
dollar
additional stimulus package then that
gets us to the subject
of inflation or deflation and the great
debate going on wall street right now
and who's going to buy all this debt and
who's going to buy
all this debt that's right so
the um i mean i'm assuming well i'm not
completely convinced that they're gonna
get it but let's say
they do i'm saying hypothetically
hypothetically if they were to do that
it would probably have to happen in
fiscal year 2122
for those that are watching the u.s
government operates on a 9 30
end-of-year calendar so after september
30th
it's a brand new year for the u.s
government so they could in theory in
october november december
launched some sort of stimulus package
that's part of the new
uh you know and have budget process what
lovely timing because
supplementary emergency unemployment
benefits
run out on september the 30th so does
rental eviction moratoriums and
forbearance for mortgages and
all these things end on september 30th
on the last day of the fiscal year
that's right so um if that were to
happen
the way i think they would structure it
it still has to be a five or ten year
type window
let's call it three to four hundred
billion a year it's
doable it's doable but it's still adding
debt upon debt and we've
we know last year was close to five
trillion in terms of overall deficits
you know we're running numbers that are
now three and a half and then if you add
this you can get to four to you can you
can get to really big numbers again
right um and that's just unusual because
i mean coming out of the financial
crisis we ran
one one and a half and that felt like
the world is ending
yeah so i mean this is this is a lot of
a lot of treasuries that someone has to
absorb
and china's already said you know we
have issues with the
rate at which the us government is
running up their debt dot dot dot
and they probably don't have enough
dollars themselves to go buy it all
because they have their own dollar
funding needs which is a whole other
issue right
but it really is going to shift the onus
to how much more does the fed have to do
can they really exit and then
you know what's the clearing rates and
then if if clearing rates get too too
high
we're noticing that because we're seeing
the markets very volatile that
you go from like you know 125 in the
10-year to 150 to 175
and things start to the wheels start to
fall off yeah so things start getting
very volatile
um if we get close to two 225 on
on the tenure without the fed hiking
let's say they're
they're true to their word and i think
they are i'm actually oh i think
i think they're i think they're serious
about this yeah they're not hiking
this idea of people like like you see it
and and it drives me bonkers like
and you know maybe it's just because
we're creatures of old you know habits
or whatever it is
but you know most of the economists that
i was reading a few there's an exception
that actually we're like no
they're really serious about the the
average inflation targeting they're not
going to move up the dots
but there's a handful they're like yes
the fed's going to you know
acknowledge that there's growth coming
and they're going to mark to market to
the
to what's priced into the fed fund strip
and the euro dollar curve yeah then
who's going to buy this theoretical next
three trillion dollars
i was like no way nobody i mean it makes
they got to keep the curve as steep as
possible give as much carry to the banks
hope the banks buy it work on some sort
of like compromise on this slr over the
next six months to a
to a year um but if in the background
the nasdaq keeps falling out of bed
because rates keep inching up
you know as as our our as our friend uh
our common friend always says
you know the top twenty percent the top
third of income earners in america so
the top the people who are in that top
third of the income wrong are
responsible for 54
of spending well if the stock market
goes down
they're gonna be a lot more prudent in
their spending
and that's a whole different way to make
the wheels fall off of the economy
yeah no so we can we were kind of
thinking in a linear fashion but
although the yield curve is not very
linear
you you throw in that third dimension
which is the wealth effect around
right so we have fed has a problem with
rates on the short end right now for the
next couple months
they have a problem how high rates can
really go they're pretending that it's
because the economy is getting better
right uh and they're acting indifferent
towards that
and then you know on the other side of
the plane of this 3d world that we live
in
is real life decisions around how
wealthy do you feel
and then how does that translate into
the trickle-down economics that they've
been
you know forcing on you know the u.s
households for the last
10 15 years one of my favorite economic
indicators is
post covid in the business and
professional services
sector subsector which is a large part
of the labor market
more than 50 of the jobs created have
been temporary
so if you're joe q ceo you're waiting to
see what's happening there's a 61
correlation co-movement between uh
between the stock market and ceo
confidence if your stock's going down
you're not hiring people
that's right it doesn't matter what what
the federal reserve is trying to say it
doesn't matter how robust you're being
told the economy is going to be
because of all this stimulus spending if
your stock price is going down you're
not hiring
that's right and it really impacts the
psyche of all those
leaders when they're looking forward
like do i want to make those
capital commitments and actually and
also the human capital commitment
which is more important in my opinion
like you're not going to do that
and like then this is why we've you know
coined the idea
and thought about you know starting
points matter
there's along the way there's short
circuits that are going to happen
yep and it's not it's not going to be a
simple
like we're going to look back and say
yep we turned on the economy everything
the vaccine is good
you know everyone's going to go back to
normal it was an inflation scare
even though we issued five trillion
dollars of debt blah blah blah there's
too much from the starting point of
going back to 1881 the stock market
being in the 99th percentile evaluations
that's right from that starting point i
mean so this is why i'm trying to say
like it's
like you know they've always in the past
trying to soft land the
economy now they're going to try to soft
land the financial markets
and it's a big task because they again
they have curves
they have the credit market which is
linked back to equities and then they
have
these high-flying growth stocks as well
as all the speculation which
right in their eyes they probably don't
care if bitcoin goes from
60 down to 10 000 or 5000 they don't
care it's small enough that
it won't be systematic to the systematic
uh issue for the nation for the
for the nation or for the financial
system but
you're gonna see people like start to
lose money they're gonna change their
behavior
right and that's the point and that's
where we get
to the fed being in this box because
they have to convince
investors they have to convince the
economics community that they're going
to let
inflation run hot but if interest rates
rise too much
and people stop hiring the wheels fall
off
and i mean that brings us to kind of the
last
big subject i want to broach so again
we're just speaking in pure
hypotheticals here but we've gone to the
end of this road together
we know how it ends so let's just say
that because they're paying people right
now who are collecting unemployment
so much money did not work they decide
that regardless of what happens
i'm not going to take this temporary job
or whatever they're going to stay out of
the
out of the labor market and continue to
collect these emergency unemployment
benefits
if they're available if they're
available and we know that they're
available through
september uc berkeley educated labor
economist janet yellen
she wants to get money to the people
she's serious about getting money to the
people
she's about the closest treasury
secretary we've ever had
who understands not necessarily the
plumbing the financial system
but she understands that there is a
transmission mechanism
to get money directly into the hands of
people she knows how helicopter money
would work yeah so let's just say this
permanent unemployment problem
persists we've got permanent
unemployment in this country that's at
the
same level as what the great financial
crisis was still today
what can she do so this is where
i i try to be a little bit more neutral
on what what this means
because i do think there's a lot of pain
and suffering out there and it's not
being addressed by having stocks at the
highs like what is that really no no i'm
not trying to imply that
no no no no no you're not i'm not i know
you're not this is no we've both been
for more targeted
relief spending instead of giving some
24 year old 1400
to put into his robin account hello yeah
i mean the money was not earmarked for
those that really needed it right they
could have done
it better they could have looked at the
unemployment roles
for every state they know who's
unemployed and just pumped up
their money or extended it even further
but yet
blank checks for everyone in the us i
mean look people like to get free money
don't get me wrong yeah but it comes
from
a cost ask any airline ceo right now
they're like we're booked out to the
summer
everybody's got money great yeah then
there's a cliff effect what do you do
after that
you expect the government to keep giving
you these kind of temporary
freebies yeah these temporary infusions
i think it was
that those things were poorly handled
and they could have been done much
better we are the united states of
america we have
the best silicon valley technology you
tell me that you cannot
figure out who's unemployed and who's
lost jobs and give them more money
instead of giving it to everybody else i
mean that makes no sense i think
everyone
you could even do something radical like
try and give them a new job skill i mean
yes which is that's where i'm getting to
so this infrastructure plan if it's done
the right way
and if it's done in a way where it's
private public partnership in an
old school fdr s bingo if it's old
school fdr
and you can again i don't want to go
back to the 1930s for the bad parts of
the 1930s right
but in terms of public works in terms of
there's a lot of things that have to get
fixed in this country
so put people to work there now the
question is can you incentivize them
enough
to pick up a shovel and a hammer and do
something that they don't want to do
instead of like staying home
like you have to get that incentive
level high enough to say
we're not going to just give you free
money you have to actually kind of work
for it but you're going to make the
country better
and then you're going to have a skill
that you can employ somewhere else this
is my this is my favorite subject george
i
i can talk about infrastructure 24 7.
and
if it's public-private partnership then
the private aspect is going to make sure
that they don't lose money
which means that taxpayer money doesn't
get lost it's a win-win
totally i mean the fiscal multipliers
have been proven over and over again to
be inefficient ways
of trying to generate growth right and
it's only gotten us to where we are now
which is a highly
indebted both at the government level as
well as the corporate level
there's just too much debt and it hasn't
really you know created
all the turns and of growth that we
should have had right so
the internal optimist i mean in the next
three to six months i can see us just
rip roaring
because there's so much liquidity oh
gosh yes i mean
it's hard to be i mean you have to you
know and you're like you do
amazing work with your your daily
updates on what's going on with economic
uh
uh activity and as well as the weeklies
but
it's it's you know it's hard to like
dismiss that wow all this money is
coming in it's impossible it's all
priced
in it's going to help out the the
industries that need it and good
good and good for that right but then
what
then what what do we do after that so
that's the part
so spring break summer vacation yes they
just they just
you know they just canceled christmas
yeah they won't
and then we know they won't right so no
so we'll have some sort of bridge maybe
we don't get the full infrastructure
plan as as we're discussing but we'll
get some sort of bridge into the into
the fourth quarter
and the real target of all this is
the midterm elections we're talking
politics already i know i'm sorry my god
i know but but you know long story short
but that's what okay
let's just let's just be apolitical and
say that that's the gop is hoping all of
this does not
work that's what they're banking on so
that they can take back the house and
the senate
and it's not a political statement to
say i hope the
opposing team loses no because it works
on both sides
right however um it's a very
delicate message to deliver still in the
midst of a pandemic
so that the key really being is you need
to get
you know the economy opening and
operating on its own two feet
to prove that it can actually operate
within a
you know a new framework of social
distancing and
increased vaccines and hope for herd
immunity
that it can prove that wait we can we're
self-sufficient look we're americans we
can actually do this
right we can get the economy back online
private economy can create
jobs amazing and make money and people
can make more money than they
will make money relying on the
government you don't need the government
to do that for everything
so that happens but hypothetically we're
running out of time
hypothetically and this is a big subject
can janet ellen deliver money directly
to the people is universal basic
income in its purest form feasible
in the united states with the current
currency construct that we have currency
and payment structure payment system
right payment system
because you you saw all the
inefficiencies and all the the horror
stories that people never got their
actual stimulus checks right they got
lost in the mail
i mean again this was back like we're 20
21 we have the best technology and
we invent everything in the us and we
can't get 1400
from the government to a person yeah
like what's wrong there
the the challenge is and you know
knowing the plumbing and how
the feds payment mechanisms which are
evolving of course over time right
but they're not in that at that place
yet
and china is playing with it so this is
this is china
this is the endgame china's starting to
in any given city in china on any given
week
they're going to have a pilot program
running where they kind of give away
monopoly money to people and they say
this is nothing real
we're just doing a little experiment
here but by the way the monopoly money
that's on your phone that we want you to
use this app to access buys real things
and it expires if you don't use it and
it expires and it expires if you don't
use it exactly
so this this uh idea of electronic cash
we're so many years away from it maybe
i'm wrong because
but what happens if china does it in two
years uh it's different we'll see
but the u.s still is the reserve
currency we'll see what
what what it means more if the us does
it uh and that's why we're taking our
time to make sure it's right
that's why i feel like we're gonna
probably have another crisis before then
right before they throw up the idea that
we have to abolish cash or not abolish
cash but really
take away the dependency on paper cash
and electronic
payments through the banking system
which is another hurdle and go directly
to the people
through some sort of wallets or direct
deposits
that i think is still down it's in the
background but look look
i was surprised i know you were too how
fast they did it in march all these
things right
so they're working on stuff as a matter
of national security if china's working
on it this hard
and other countries like russia and
venezuela have already gone there
somebody is in somebody in the state
department somebody
in the pentagon somebody at the new york
fed they're working on it i mean boston
fed actually has a big uh joint venture
with i think mit or somebody
okay and they're working out so they've
got the smartest people in the world
yeah and they're working on it yeah
and like most mit folks run the fed or
central banks around the world right
so um i i think it's it's coming but i
don't think it's going to be in
place at a time where janet yellen or
just through the fed channel treasury
money into the
banking system will happen yeah i still
think they're going to need another
crisis
yeah we need another question we don't
want well which we don't want or we need
to
get into this slow burn i mean i'm over
the slow burn
uh philosophy for the medium term and
then relatively optimistic the long term
because i think
i think that freedom loving people are
still going to want to have their
privacy
they're going to still want to have
access to their capital and cash
and they're not going to want everyone
watching every little step that they're
doing we're not a monitoring type
country this is not the kgb i don't
think the fed wants that either deep
down inside
no rare that these words come out of my
mouth but to jay powell's credit he's
always said if there's a fed coin if
there's a digital currency
it will be just as anonymous as the
dollar bill in your wallet we will not
be spying on you
yes i i generally believe with that i
mean they could probably track patterns
and
do other sort of analysis but i think
it's it'll be meant
to to address some of these short-term
issues because
at the end of the day as we've seen all
along they overflood it when there's a
problem and then it becomes inefficient
monetary policy
if there's much more targeted like look
we have a hurricane that hit
you know south florida and it needs a
lot of money
and the banks are offline or whatever
you can get it into your phone
right you can take that phone with a qr
code and pay for food
like hey this is what the world is
moving towards so a central bank that's
smart
to jump on that is is is important
and what the chinese are doing with
their payment system i mean i think it's
very local
it's still small it's embryonic i don't
think the world's going to embrace it
either
i think the us dollar and whatever
e-dollar fed coin that we
invent will still be the basis for a lot
of transactions so great country
love american innovation love american
cars
yes all right so my father was too
spoiled son of immigrants
got into university of connecticut 1964
stingray
wrapped himself around a light pole
eight surgeries later they managed to
save him which is why i'm here
this is good i was partial to the 1966
however i recently saw the brand new
corvette
and wow i mean wow you can you can put
that next to mclaren and it's a
beautiful i was in florida that's where
they drive all these things of course
yeah so but i but the brand new corvette
so
all right what's the best year of
corvette
by the way george we're both gear heads
huge gear bigger gearhead than i am
so i mean just so because this is
important what's the best
corvette that was ever made in america i
can go down go down lingo i mean
i've seen people what's called d badging
they take off the corvette symbols and
chevy
and they pretend it's mclaren because it
really looks that good
i mean it's it's a very easy okay that's
not nice because
you've got to be people proud of that
american car
fine whatever but i'm joking uh no it's
an amazing car
um 24 hours of daytona years ago beat
the ferrari
both u.s corvettes even though they put
anything under the hood but anyways the
best vintage
it's a tough one i mean i i mean i do
like the 1960s
those stingrays were the stingrays were
really you know just a classic
they don't take regular unleaded though
uh it's hard to drive nowadays
you have to really find the special
place to do that my i mean i personally
have
two corvettes so i have a 1990 corvette
zr1 which i rebuilt myself
i know um i'm jealous and uh and so
that's my personal favorite because i
went
i'm a kid from the 80s 90s and so i
always want to have a
1990s corvette zr1 which was half
european half
kind of like me i'm like yeah portuguese
and
and american so it was a perfect
combination of
european technology on which still an
amazing engine
it operates yeah 32 valve for four cam
they're allies that's okay yeah lotus in
uk
uh and uh yeah so i would say that
probably
started the cutting edge side of
of corvette engineering and they started
to up the ante and then
all the subsequent corvettes have been
just amazing and then i have a modern
day
pre which is called c7 the new one is
called c8
they go by vintages so like c4 is the
one that i have which is the corvette
zero next down the middle with george
and danielle is gonna be
on a race track we're just gonna get a
fast camera to go with us
which by the way i'm also a part of a
racing club with uh
of course you are and which you kind of
have to be uh there's a
great uh place down in new jersey called
the new jersey motorsports speedway i'm
a member down there
because i you can't go fast in the
streets not these cars
but i've taken it up to like 170 it's
it's oh it's
my new corvette which i supercharged and
i have a over 800 horsepower
it's it's insane it looks like i can
spin i can spin it in third gear i mean
just like
my oldest who's a gearhead so he's a
fourth generation gearhead i'm gonna let
him watch like the last five minutes of
this interview and he's like
mom how do you know him and we have to
go visit him in new jersey i can hear it
now
no it's it's definitely a passion of
mine and it really to be honest
in a weird kind of nerdy way is what got
me
really interested in fixed income too i
would study
every single fact sheet of how you know
bonds
i mean i'm sorry how cars are put
together right like you know how the
just overall the camp shaft lobes what's
going on with what kind of gear ratios
i mean i like new stats like people
would know baseball rbis for their
favorite players that's
the true gear head stuff going on here
and you can't ever run out of liquidity
with a car either
no it's in your uppercut so if you can
do that sort of stuff then you apply it
to understanding
all kind of bond descriptions and all
the sort of things that make a bond work
you can be future rape strategists i
hope you're paying attention finance
majors right now just
go figure out how to take a car apart
and put it back together that's right
george
thank you thank you so much this was
very timely all this stuff is happening
as we speak we
so appreciate your time and i hope we
can do this again soon likewise my
pleasure
thanks for having me well now you might
have a better
idea of why when i was in high school
they called me a nerd
i really do love to get into the weeds
to understand
the plumbing of the financial system
there's no nobody understands it better
than george
and i hope you enjoyed that if you
didn't understand a few of the terms
just google them
and you'll thank me for it later uh one
of george
and my one of our shared inspirations
richard werner
he he was in embedded in tokyo
when the massive crash happened in 1989
he did extraordinary work
uh and and so i've also interviewed him
if you want to look back at a little bit
more in depth uh
look see at what happened then and
whether or not there are implications
for what's happening in the united
states now so be sure
and catch that interview if you missed
it and of course if you have not
subscribed
please do subscribe please subscribe
uh and i look forward to the next time
for the next edition of down the middle
thank you
you